[Music]
not an ordinary election
not an ordinary time the words of
incumbent prime minister jacinda ardern
after she secured a rare outright
majority
the first in decades
tonight new zealand has shown the labour
party
its greatest support in at least 50
years
we have seen that support in both urban
areas and in rural areas
and seats we may have hoped for but in
those equally we may not have expected
ardern won a second term after steering
the country through a series of crises
after the christchurch mosque shootings
last year ardern swiftly banned
military-style weapons
and introduced a gun buyback scheme
she won praise for her handling of the
covet 19 crisis
the country has recorded only 25 deaths
so far
ardern also became the second world
leader to give birth
while in office
her main challenge was from judith
collins of the conservative national
party
but her blunt no-nonsense approach
failed to resonate
with voters after the celebrations
ardern's challenge will be to steer the
country out of its deepest recession in
more
than 30 years
i'm joined now by samantha earley a
journalist in christchurch
samantha good to have you with us it's
looking like not just
a win but a historic victory for ardern
was she expected to win by such a large
margin
well a lot of polls had predicted a
victory some
uh this sort of out majority that we've
seen tonight but
most were predicting a that she would
need to form a coalition government
with the greens and um under our
electoral system here in new zealand
coalition governments
um are what's been favored
what's usually needed to form a
governing majority
so it is quite a historic moment that
labor has picked up enough to
potentially govern alone
what has she briefly outlined as her
plan for the next term
well it's it's really um building back
better
from the covert crisis she told
supporters they
plan to carry on investing in
infrastructure things like training
and um that they now have the the
mandate to accelerate
those plans jacinda ardern
is very popular internationally you must
know i mean winning praise for her
reaction to the pandemic as well as that
that right-wing terrorist attack in
christ
church but i wonder as we consider these
results if she faced any criticism at
all
for her handling of other critical
issues that the country clearly faces
yes domestically plenty of criticism
actually
um although that widespread very
widespread support
um the other success story of this
election was the act party the free
market uh libertarian party who's
been very uh vocal probably one of the
most vocal
uh in terms of uh criticizing various
labor policies
and uh they've gone from point five
percent of the vote
last time to eight percent now moving
from one member of parliament to 10.
um so that shows you something about
the um yes some opposition there to
ardern
and and also yeah you have to expect a
scrutiny of the debt
that the government's going into with
the covert response
and the opposition leader the national
leader judith collins said
that new zealand is in for a tough
economic ride and
that it's going to need better fiscal
policy uh
than we have so far seen that's what
judith collins said and she
also said expect a national once they've
had a bit of time to reflect to be a
robust opposition
so a lot of challenges there for jacinda
ardern also in key areas where she
promised or outlined really wanting to
make transformational change things like
housing climate change and child poverty
widely seen as areas where not as much
progress was made
in these past three years as a lot of
her supporters and new zealanders would
have liked so big challenges there for
her
samantha early in christ church thank
you so much
you